[Music]
[Laughter]
what is happening reject nation greg and
john here today we're gonna watch from
the channel canadian lad i watched zack
snyder's justice league in 0.25 speed
and here's what i found now i've been a
big canadian lad fan for a very long
time now fantastic channel soaring for a
reason it was around when this video
came out when i was trying to get his
go-ahead to be able to cover his videos
i didn't get to go ahead until recently
i've intentionally and avoided this
specific one for the day he would
finally say yes you can cover our video
now we are here zack snyder's justice
league i was gonna wait till september
7th but i'm like screw it let's just
watch it now man this is when i was like
we gotta start covering canadian like
this is the
this is what is when i really wanted to
see
[Music]
hey everyone i'm the canadian lad and i
have watched zack snyder's justice
league at point tvx speed which took me
well over four days so i had to make
this one count and guess what i found 25
new details from the film some of which
will literally blow your mind and make
you appreciate the snyder cut even more
let's go when the flash fights superman
for the first time the flash was ready
to use this special power against
superman let me explain look at how
flash raises his hand as superman
prepares to shoot his laser beam the
flash signaled with the same gesture
against the end which allowed him to
face through and survive the blast so
this raise of hand is something that
activates his phasing ability and the
fact that he made the same gesture when
someone was about to shoot his laser
beam goes to show that this hand gesture
is barry getting ready to do whatever is
necessary to survive and yes i did
notice this ben parker easter egg at
this point who didn't so i'm not
including it in the list number two
watch go for a shadow you know that
aries makes a huge blow on darkseid's
right shoulder he not only managed to
make a massive cut on his right shoulder
but he did it through darkseid's armor
but here's what i noticed one of my
favorite details from the film notice
after all these years darkseid didn't
even bother to fix his armor all
together he's still carrying the memory
of his only loss this shows just how
pissed he is at what happened ah that is
such a good production design detail and
you know that someone like zack snyder
would keep that intentionally oh yeah
like this is the kind of character who
would want to be reminded of his losses
so he could he's the kind of character
who would feel the burden that pain have
it be served as a reminder he's carrying
a literal chip on his shoulder
that is great i never noticed that when
bruce wayne brings all of his work
friends to the bat cave alfred offers to
make them some tea but then says this
i'll put on the tea
great
i don't know where we're gonna find the
cups probably because nobody ever goes
there except him and bruce but notice
when bruce was talking about his
nightmare in the background we can see
some cuts so it seems as though alfred
did manage it
they're all different
they're all different
pay attention to the left side of the
screen here we can see darkseid looking
down on the funeral so he's clearly
allowing the amazons to feel the pain of
losing one of their best i think it was
probably darkseid who left the amazon
set up a funeral in the first place and
that's just badass also notice the way
darkseid turns around comes forward a
little and stands there this is the
exact same vfx model of dark side that
snyder used to later in the climax again
but from a different angle i gotta say
zack snyder and company are amazing at
taking the same shots from things
reusing them and not having to be not
noticing like i rarely ever i'm like is
that the same shot
it's working so well every time i get
the most you can out of those cg assets
so for as expensive and time consuming
as they are to make i'm glad you pointed
that out canadian that was a really good
catch darkseid's omega beam was a
satisfaction for all the dc fans
especially seeing it underwater the
omega beam even boiled the water right
there but that's not my detail i'm gonna
freeze this frame right here now tell me
what do you see nothing yet how about
now another detail number six
was super heating the motherbox making
its core the hottest thing on earth
silas realized steppenwolf will get the
motherbox so he infused his signatures
to it which would allow the heroes to
locate it before the unity happened but
in the process he had to sacrifice
himself now notice while he was getting
vaporized he started bleeding from the
left side of his chest first meaning his
heart kudos to the bfx team for such
accuracy
number seven this one is possibly my
favorite detail that i found in this
movie exactly 24 minutes and five
seconds of the film are in slow motion
mostly because that's the best way to
showcase flash's abilities but it's
always nice to see his speed from
someone else's perspective and that's
what we got to see in this film when the
flash was saving the civilians from the
falling debris i actually managed to see
what it really does at pointy fabric
speed he taps the rocks flying kicks
them punches them and stands in the
center of the group looking up but here
comes my favorite part for three frames
you can even see him standing on the
side thinking about what to do next so
even though all of this happened
that's an amazing detail sadly most
people don't even notice whoa
that is a massive
massive
reasoning for canadian lad to exist
absolutely absolutely you would not have
caught that at all had you not slowed it
down a
is 0.25 speed because yeah i had no idea
what the hell he was doing and obviously
he was like moving rocks and [ __ ] but to
have like that moment where he's moving
so fast that he takes time to wonder it
it's pretty much like how when you watch
the slow down scene in the movie itself
when he's saving iris west you get to
watch him think about what to do but
here it's happening in the super fast
motion and i love that they gave that
attention to detail where it's still
like let ezra miller do a performance
even though it's going by whiplash face
it's brilliant that is brilliant i love
this movie
when louis lane visits a coffee shop at
the beginning of the film zack snyder
appears in the background as well i know
most of you knew this detail already but
i just wanted to include it as a thank
you to zack snyder number nine lois lane
has a pregnancy test kit on a drawer i
love that flashlight congratulations as
well congratulations by the way now zack
snyder has confirmed that lewis and
clark are indeed having a baby zach had
planned that their son would be born
without any powers and eventually become
the new batman number 10 at the end of
the film when martian manhunter takes
off from bruce wayne's house if you
watch this scene at pointy fabric speed
you'll notice the hall of justice or
wayne manor is under construction a very
very subtle easter egg but it's kind of
funny that people keep wondering who
batman is while bruce wayne literally
lives a mile away from the hall of
justice
time travels and reverses the explosion
the body of superman starts to
re-materialize but notice when the same
thing happens for cyborg the vfx
department made sure to only put flash
on his face and not his body i know most
of you let's have probably noticed it
too at regular speed but it looks so
much better in slow motion you gotta
give credits to the vfx team for such
attention absolutely absolutely when
victor gets a vision of the nightmare
timeline he sees superman crying with
the dead body of lois lane on his arm
the dark side enslaves superman probably
with the nt life and notice in the
background we can see robin's suit that
we've previously seen in batman v
superman so this is
this event is taking place in the battle
in the background where superman becomes
evil in the nightmare timeline oh now
he's a batman
initially when there was no hope of
getting a snyder cut in a q a session
zack snyder actually revealed his plans
for justice league 2. had zach continued
to work on the dc extended universe
justice league 2 would somewhat look
like this batman convinced the league
that they should catch dark side by
surprise before he invades the earth
again so superman entrusts batman to
keep lewis safe with him so they hide
her in the bat cave but darkseid finds
it out and goes to the bat cave and
kills her this triggers the nightmare as
seen in victor's vision and the chaos
continues until last travels back in
time to warn bruce about what happens
but flash mistakenly arrives at an
earthquake
but then he travels again to the right
moment and tells bruce to save lois at
any cost this time batman sacrifices his
life instead of lois and the league
defeats darkseid as well and this is how
justice league 2 and 3 would have panned
out that is
so cool that
zack snyder literally thought how do i
take a scene out of what i had planned
in like justice league i don't know if
this was originally that that scene in
there of lois being burnt to a crisp and
superman holding her in his hands was
gonna be in the original version of this
of of the of justice league for him
knowing like his odds of getting a
justice league too don't seem likely but
to implement that and tease it within
there and then let it be known like no
yeah there's the batcave right there
just would see the robin out because i
had no idea where that location was and
the movie doesn't even say specifically
who superman is holding knowing what
zack snyder's plans are and then seeing
the location setting literally having
the bat the bad suit there from bvs
confirms it all how does that
description not make you want to see how
this all planned
so awesome even if they just do exactly
what's blended it was so awesome yeah
the harrowing yeah god
ah [ __ ] we gotta get it back come on
discovery barry acknowledges that using
his power causes him to lose an extreme
amount of calories which is unsafe so he
has to consume a lot of calories to
balance it out which he calls a snack
hole caused me to burn a tremendous
amount of calories i am a snack hole now
look at what alfred prepared for barry a
huge bowl of ruffle ships number
fourteen at the end of the film lex
luthor offers deathstrokes galleries
book care for a glass of gouda
now this champagne is sold in the real
world for 1.4 million dollars a bottle
just a random fact i thought the lads
would like to know number fifteen at the
end of the film during the nightmare
sequence this shot of superman slowly
looking upwards is a reused footage from
batman v superman there you go to save
some money there number 16 batman tells
alfred that superman will come back
alfred asks what makes you so sure
batman replies faith alfred faith if you
watched man of steel there's a similar
scene where a father from a church tells
clark about the leap of faith sometimes
you have to take a leap of faith first
the trust part comes later so a nice
little connection there and i'm so happy
snyder has doubled down on this because
faith is one of batman's core
characteristics i mean i know we haven't
really been dissecting like the snyder
verse as frequently when all the films
were super super fresh in my mind but
that is one thing that i really love
about the whole experience of watching
the connective tissue between the three
because it is one of those things where
all the arcs are occurring within this
massive storyline here it's not just
what's the next adventure for them to go
on i thought that all three films had
this great superman arc about
self-acceptance to tie it back in with
faith with batman who was not a believer
in bbs
and to go here and then making that that
full complete like trilogy of the three
snyder films that have come out is a
nice like character nuance beat there
because superman needed to have faith
himself batman having faith that he
overturned superman does return help
save the day it's just such a beautiful
progression of all the movies yeah i
love it so much well it makes you
appreciate it that much more because
it's not only plot beats that are
connecting them it's themes and concepts
and challenges for the characters that
then become shared down the line yeah
man oh beautiful stuff when barry sneaks
into the star lab he shows a fake id now
in josh whedon's cut there was a mistake
in the date of birth which would make
barry's fake profile only a seven year
old kid but in the snyder cut it is
fixed number 18 whenever cyborg sees a
vision or when he has to fight for the
mother boxes at the end he always
imagines himself in his human form but
notice as soon as he comes in terms with
this new life that he has he no longer
imagines himself in his human form
victor has accepted the way he is now
number 19 in the final battle when
superman arrives for the first time and
says not impressed it's actually taken
directly from the comics number twenty
after oh really
there's a billboard here that says you
are not alone this is a real life
foundation that works to prevent
suicides one of the focal elements in
the snyder cut campaign was to donate to
this charity number 21 in order to
revive superman the league needed
additional charge from flash to generate
power and after flash successfully
transmits that power he didn't have
enough space to slow down so he crashed
into superman's ship now a lot of people
seem to think that barry faced through
the wall of superman's ship but here's
the proof that he broke the wall and
didn't phase it through it
at this point he probably smiled a bit
when batman said this about alfred
everyone this is alfred i work for him
so even though it's the other way around
but out of respect to alfred he said the
opposite we saw a similar sort of
interaction in christopher nolan's
batman trilogy as well number 23 batman
was standing on his bat tank aka war
machine near the end of the film this is
straight from the dark knight returns
comics but notice the mutant gang from
the same comics
[Music]
that their like attention to the comic
book details as well as just the script
supervision is off the charts on this
movie that is insane
he made zack snyder has said that he
would love to do a direct adaptation of
the dark knight uh returns
no yeah mm-hmm
right this is the move direction
remake of the dark night yeah he would
love to do a direct adaptation of the
dark knight return the way how he did
watchmen like a shot for shot and i'd be
down for that i mean a thousand percent
down for that he's the guy
he's the guy to do it right never rob
rodriguez if you wanted to look for it
actually like it didn't do a direct
break
yeah yeah those are your guys
they could collab i want to see that
oh that's so awesome in barry allen's
intro scene pay attention to the truck
involved in the accident it says
gardner-fox which is a reference to dc
comics writer gardner fox who co-created
both the flash and justice league as
well as introduce the multiverse to dc
number 25 in the scene where bruce wayne
meets barry allen for the first time in
the background we can see some
hand-drawn designs that barry's been
working on you can see he tried to go
for an emblem that is similar to
and that's it this would be my breakdown
of zack snyder's justice league at point
25x speed and i'll admit it's a thousand
times better than what we've got back in
2017 but if you think about it you can't
really release a four hour film in
theaters at least not from the business
perspective especially not the way you
watch movies
a 16 hour film we finally got the snyder
cut and i think it does justice to most
of the characters especially victor and
barry's if you like this video then
please give me a thumbs up grab
official merchandise from the canadian
lab.merchforall.com
follow me on instagram and twitter to
get updates about my videos till then
i'll see you lads in the next one
thank you so much canadian lad that was
brilliant absolutely brilliant guys
subscribe to canadian land if you
haven't done so already hashtag restore
the snyderverse thank you so much for
being here that was so crazy after all
these months to still discover new
details man i know a lot of you guys
probably saw this video ages ago but for
for me i was especially that mutants one
the flash of mutants the flash and
mutants one best ones that was amazing
that was so awesome i'd love the hell
out of that
all right guys leave your thoughts down
below yeah we'll catch you guys soon